This is our first lecture
on text analytics.
We'll discuss how can
use data from Twitter
and turn them into knowledge.
Twitter is a social
networking and communication
website founded in 2006.
Users share and
send messages that
can be no longer than
140 characters long.
It is indeed one of the
Top 10 most visited sites
on the internet.
It had an initial
public offering in 2013,
and it's current valuation
is about $31 billion.
Let's discuss the
impact of Twitter.
Protesters around the
world use Twitter.
It had an important
impact on Arab Spring.
People also use it as a
method of notification
for natural disasters and
for tracking diseases.
Celebrities, politicians,
and companies
connect with fans and
customers using Twitter.
Everyone is watching.
To illustrate this
last point, let
us discuss a tweet
that was supposed
to be from the Associated Press.
The Associated Press
is a major news agency
that distributes news stories
to other news agencies.
In April 2013, someone
tweeted this message
from the main AP
verified Twitter account.
It said that two explosions
in the White House and Barack
Obama is injured.
The S&P 500 stock index
fell 1% in seconds,
but the White House
rapidly clarified.
Many companies maintain
online presences.
Managing public perception in
an age of instant communication
is essential.
Reacting to changing sentiment,
identifying offensive posts,
determining topics of
interest are indeed crucial.
In this lecture,
we'll see how we
can use analytics to
address these questions.